avant d'aller plus loin et pour bien
mesurer l'ampleur de ces actes de guerre
pour reprendre l'expression de georges
bush on va revoir comment les habitants
de new york ont vécu cette journée du 11
septembre des témoignages poignants
illustré aussi par de nouvelles images
des attentats c'est sans commentaire
montage daniel wolfromm je travaille
tout en bas dans wall street et de d'une
des fenêtres de mon immeuble
on peut voir une des tours du world
trade center qui est complètement en feu
c'est à dire qu'en fait elle n'est pas
en fait on voit pas les flammes mais il
ya une énorme bande de fumée noire qui
s'échappe des fenêtres sur à peu près 30
étages les 30 derniers étages de
l'immeuble est donc une grande colonne
de fumée noire qui monte
j'ai l'impression que ces genres la tour
infernale le truc on voit vraiment la
fumée qui s'échappe à gros morceau du
truc quoi celle angoisse un aveugle de
paris des avions ont le droit de
survoler manhattan donc tu vois souvent
des avions ont survolé le la ville et
moi quand j'ai attaqué quand j'ai vu la
fumée d'abord est condamné on sait que
c'est un avion qui s'écrase dans on
s'est dit on c'est divin de l'accident
est arrivé tout le monde a pensé à un
accident comme ça
l'avion qui s'écrase dans les twin
towers c1 mais mais de savoir que c'est
un acteur qu'est street terrorisme c'est
quand même hallucinant
après des grandes santé connexes de lyon
un grain de bouche de ceux et ensuite
dirigés vers l'endroit besoin d'écoles
de montcy c'est là si un grand feu y
avait on a vu tous ces agents de qui
sont sautés de 2,2 de ce dernier étage
de la world trade center on aboutit
toujours à voler des jeux naissance
j'étais quittés heureux
2 en dessous du stis heures au dessus de
feu c'était horrible s'il n'y a pas de
nom pour qualifier ces horribles et on
était tous ceux en état de choc c'est
horrible c'est ça fait comme une
éruption de volcan le tout tout le bas
de la ville est couverte de 2 m 2 de
sambre comme s'il y avait un volcan en
éruption
on peut avoir sur sa télévision locale
on ne sait pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé
s'il ya des choses qui se passe ailleurs
dans le monde on n'arrive même pas à
concevoir encore que ça a vraiment eu
lieu de ce matin cette chose assez
horrible et après le deuxième s'est
écroulé alors là les gens hurlaient dans
la rue il est choquant paris pleurait ya
des gens qui vomissent ex tout le monde
essayait téléphoner mais les lignes
téléphoniques marchaient très mal ça
doit être comme ça pendant la guerre ce
pensent à 9 heures tous les employés
étaient présents cc c'est énorme ça
s'est passé aux influences soul voit
tout et chanteur c'est une façon c'est
une grosse station de métro et train
tous les gens qui viennent du new-jersey
de saïda réseau il arrive aux bolton
faveur ce qui fait qu'il ait énormément
de monde à ce moment là on va revoir le
trotteur et c'est terrible terrible
c'est inimaginable
voilà